voilà excusez-nous encore pour ce retard
d'une vingtaine de minutes mais nous
étions dans l'hémicycle pour votre en
scrutin public solennelle donc merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation pour
participer donc à cette audition notre
commission d'enquête donc nous
accueillons aujourd'hui Monsieur Franck
Lacroix vous occupez ces fonctions
auprès de qui est directeur général
adjoint d'engie et vous occupez vos
fonctions auprès de Catherine McGregor
depuis le mois de février 2023 et vous
êtes également membre du comité exécutif
du groupe avant de rejoindre engie vous
avez exercé de nombreuses fonctions dans
l'énergie et les services notamment chez
Dalkia EDF mais aussi à la SNCF et chez
Elior
Madame Florence Fouquet en votre qualité
de Directrice des marchés particuliers
d'engie donc en tant qu'ingénieur de
mine vous avez développé une première
partie de carrière au sein du ministère
de l'économie et des finances dans le
domaine de l'énergie puis chez engie
vous avez été en charge des clients
professionnels puis à partir de 2018 des
clients particuliers soit 5,5 millions
de clients et 8 millions de contrats de
services
engie est l'un des principaux acteurs de
l'énergie en France et de plus en plus à
l'étranger historiquement acteur du gaz
l'entreprise se diversit vers d'autres
sources d'énergie angie est aussi
fournisseur direct des particuliers et à
développer à ce titre une branche de
service qui est labellisée RGE c'est à
ces différents titres que nous vous
auditionnons aujourd'hui en premier lieu
nous voudrions savoir quelle est la
vision d'engie sur la TRA l'histoire de
décarbonation et sur la sortie des
énergies fossiles n'est-ce qu'un chemin
vers l'électrification des usages cette
trajectoire est-elle soutenable et à
quelles conditions plus particulièrement
dans le logement notamment sous pression
européenne il semble que la
décarbonation prenne le pas sur
l'isolation et sur la sobriété est-ce
une bonne chose le tout pompe à chaleur
sans isolation ne va-t-il pas entraîner
des déconvenus pour les ménages pour la
gestion du réseau électrique mais aussi
pour la planète avec comme effet
secondaire le développement de la
climatisation
acteur central de l'énergie angie est
donc aussi un des principaux obligés en
matière de certificat d'économie
d'énergie nous voudrions savoir quel est
votre vision du dispositif est-il
suffisamment cohérent et suffisamment
articulée avec les autres aides les
délégataires et les opérateurs qui
réalisent les travaux sont-ils
suffisamment contrôlées peut-on
simplifier et unifier tout cela enfin
comment lutter contre une fraude qui
sans être général et tout de même très
répandu je voudrais enfin que vous nous
présentiez le volet service aux
particuliers Kenji a développé pour
favoriser la rénovation énergétique quel
est votre retour d'expérience à ce sujet
Comment peut-on amener les ménages vers
la rénovation globale de leur bien
quel regard porte engie sur mon
accompagnateur rénov enfin je l'ai dit
engie et labellisé RGE quelle est votre
vision de ce label et comment
pourrait-il évoluer pour apporter plus
de garanties au ménage et concernés un
plus grand nombre d'entreprises
notamment artisanales voilà avant de
vous laisser la parole pour répondre à
ses premières questions qui sont déjà
bien complètes et qui font un tour
d'horizon assez large du sujet il me
revient de vous indiquer que notre
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'un compte rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passibles des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende je vous invite
donc madame monsieur a prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
a levé la main droite et à dire je le
jure
je le jure merci Monsieur le Directeur
Général
merci Madame la Directrice donc je vous
laisse la parole pour répondre déjà à
ces quelques questions et ensuite
monsieur le rapporteur et des membres de
la commission il y en a déjà un qui est
présent et si d'autres ne rejoignent
pourront également nous poser nous poser
un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires voilà
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs les sénateurs
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier de
nous donner l'opportunité d'intervenir
sur ce sujet très important de la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
dans lequel engie vous l'avez dit
intervient au fond bien au-delà de son
rôle historique de fournisseurs et
distributeurs de gaz en France
engie a centré son rôle en fait sa
stratégie je dirais même sur la
transition énergétique avec en
particulier depuis 2020 une raison
d'être qui est inscrit dans ces statuts
et qui se résume à inviter chacun des
membres de ce groupe agir pour accélérer
la transition énergétique vers une
économie neutre en carbone notre
trajectoire propre engie c'est
d'atteindre cette neutralité carbone sur
les trois scopes à horizon 2045 on peut
en avance par rapport au rendez-vous je
dirais plus traditionnel de 2050
nous intervenons en France naturellement
mais aussi dans à peu près 30 pays et
nous le faisons dans le cadre d'une
démarche intégrée que je trouve au fond
très original contenu de mon histoire
dans le monde des services et de
l'énergie en général je n'ai pas vu ça
ailleurs une démarche donc intégrée qui
aborde au fond la mutation du système
énergétique par trois aspects le premier
c'est d'abord la production d'énergie
renouvelable
solaire éolien offshore offshore etc sur
lequel nous production d'énergie
renouvelable nous investissons très
fortement pour passer à l'échelle du
groupe de d'une puissance actuelle de 38
gigawatts pour atteindre 80 gigawatts à
horizon de 2030
nous intervenons ensuite sur un deuxième
aspect qui est en fait la transformation
des je dirais des infrastructures de
transport de distribution et aussi
celles qui vont contribuer à la
flexibilité indispensable du système
énergétique qui est un sujet qui devient
de plus en plus importante parce que le
système énergétique ou vous l'avez dit
également aura une tendance à devenir de
plus en plus électrique et on connaît la
difficulté de l'électricité qui
nécessite une équilibre un équilibre
permanent entre au fond la production et
la consommation électricité ne se stocke
pas
nous avons sur ce sujet là d'ailleurs
une conviction qui est que la résilience
du système elle passe en fait par
l'alliance de la molécule et de
l'électron la molécule de gaz bien sûr
qui a aussi vocation à ce décarboner
avec le biométhane aujourd'hui
l'hydrogène peut être un peu plus tard
mais on commence à y travailler très
très sérieusement d'ailleurs
donc cette molécule de gaz elle permet
d'offrir ce système qui est de plus en
plus au fond complexe interconnecté la
flexibilité et la fiabilité qui est
indispensable à son fonctionnement il ne
s'agit pas seulement de décarboner
quelque chose il s'agit d'avoir un
système qui soit fiable pour qu'on
puisse vivre et produire en toute
sécurité et puis le troisième volet de
notre intervention ce sont en fait les
infrastructures et les équipements
énergétiques des consommateurs
pour les aider en fait à les décarboner
et dans ce cadre et je crois que c'est
très important par rapport au sujet du
jour dans ce cas nous agissons en fait
sur trois leviers qui sont distincts et
complémentaires d'abord
l'efficacité énergétique l'efficacité
énergétique ça revient en fait aux
bornes d'un système énergétique à en
réduire les pertes
et à améliorer donc les rendements des
équipements énergétiques tout en
délivrant bien sûr
l'énergie et les services associés qui
sont en général et en grande majorité le
chauffage l'eau chaude et la
climatisation avec un niveau de qualité
de confort qui soit conforme aux
attentes des
occupants du bâtiment et on sait qu'ils
sont divers les attentes comme les
occupants d'ailleurs
et deuxième donc l'efficacité
énergétique le deuxième volet qui est
distingue du premier c'est la sobriété
énergétique et ça ça consiste au fond si
on veut faire simple à supprimer le
gaspillage
par exemple ne pas chauffer un bâtiment
inoccupé par exemple
un sujet qui est très important qui est
les usages intermittents d'un bâtiment
les équipements que les écoles les
choses comme ça ou là il y a vraiment
des leviers importants mais ça peut être
aussi toujours dans la surbritée de
modifier peut-être un peu les pratiques
des occupants par exemple
accepter que les boucles d'eau chaude
sanitaire
se fassent sans préchauffage vous
connaissez le principe dans beaucoup
d'installations historiques il y avait
une boucle qui circulait dans tout un
bâtiment pour que l'eau dès qu'on ouvre
un robinet chaud sorte chaude bien
aujourd'hui c'est discuter ça représente
des consommations pas négligeables alors
de 5% d'un bâtiment on va dire pour
faire simple et bien si on n'a pas cette
boucle d'eau chaude l'eau elle arrive un
peu tiède et puis elle arrive chaude un
peu plus tard c'est peut-être pas aussi
grave au fond c'est aussi c'est qu'on
peut rassimiler ça je dirais à du
gaspillage et puis après toujours dans
la sob riété il peut y avoir aussi des
changements de pratique bon bah là qui
peut-être efface évoluer nos critères de
confort par exemple baisser d'un degré
la température et on sait que la loi dit
que les bâtiments doivent être chauffés
à 19 degrés on sait bien que la pratique
est sans doute différente
l'efficacité énergétique la sobriété
énergétique et le troisième volet de
notre action si le recours prioritaire
bien sûr aux énergies renouvelables donc
on est intéressé au moins deux titres
par la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments d'abord en tant qu'acteur de
cette transformation sur la partie des
systèmes énergétiques que je viens de
citer qui est une activité en tant que
telle et qui d'ailleurs
existe
depuis longtemps en fait et on est
également concerné par notre rôle de
fournisseur d'énergie puisque nous
sommes au titre des certificats
d'économie d'énergie obligée par ce
dispositif c'est une obligation pour
nous qui pèse à peu près 500 millions
d'euros par an pour engie dans l'actuel
phase des certificats d'économie
d'énergie
alors ensuite en 2020 les bâtiments
résidentiel et tertiaires ça
représentait 47% de la consommation
d'énergie
et 23% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre donc la rénovation de énergétique
de ces bâtiments c'est bien sûr un
pilier fondamental dans l'atteinte des
objectifs de décarbonation de la France
il est donc évidemment plus que légitime
de s'interroger sur
les dispositifs d'accompagnement de ces
démarches de rénovation pour nous vu
d'un énergéticien le bâtiment est une
notion qui est très large en fait et qui
regroupe des réalités très différentes
pour nous on l'aborde à partir de
la configuration des équipements
énergétiques
pour l'essentiel qui sont je vous
l'avais dit qu'on se fait pour le
chauffage l'eau chaude et la
climatisation il y a d'un côté
les bâtiments avec des installations
énergétiques collectives
et donc c'est tout le bâtiment tertiaire
public ou privé mais c'est aussi
l'habitat collectif avec des
installations énergétiques collectives
que ce soit dans le monde social ou dans
le monde privé
cet ensemble-là ça représente 45 % des
consommations d'énergie et puis il y a
tout le reste donc des bâtiments des
maisons individuelles ou des bâtiments
collectifs avec des équipements à
l'intérieur individuels et ça ça
représente le complément pour ce qui est
la partie collective en fait chez engie
c'est géré à travers ce qu'on appelle
engie solution que je dirige avec une
orientation qui aujourd'hui très forte
donnée sur les économies d'énergie sur
la durée
à travers de ce qu'on appelle des
contrats de performance énergétique et
j'y reviendrai
donc
sur la deuxième partie ils sont adressés
en fait par Florence Fouquet dont la
mission est bien sûr d'abord de vendre
de l'électricité aux particuliers ou du
gaz mais aussi des services associés et
en particulier donc
toute la gestion de la réduction enfin
des équipements des accompagnements on
va dire sur la performance énergétique
pour en particulier les certificats
d'économie d'énergie mais pas seulement
et donc en fait les approches entre ces
deux grandes catégories de bâtiments au
sein d'engie sont très différentes pour
une raison toute simple c'est que elle
s'adresse à des écosystèmes qui sont
très différents d'un côté au fond dans
le collectif ce qu'on appelle de B2B et
c'est pas la même chose que de l'autre
côté sur l'individuel où on est dans le
monde du B2C
alors peut-être je voudrais juste avant
de revenir à quelques suggestions très
concrètes sur votre question peut-être
je dirais reposer le sujet dans le
contexte énergétique global et vous m'y
invitiez d'ailleurs dans votre propos au
moment où en fait vous le savez le
calendrier se précise là sur la
programmation énergétique française il
est évident que la rénovation
énergétique du bâtiment doit s'intérêt
dans une version dans une vision
générale du système énergétique sa
trajectoire qui combine qui combine la
réduction de l'intensité énergétique et
le choix des vecteurs énergétiques les
plus appropriés
et moi je voudrais insister là-dessus
sur trois points d'abord sur l'intensité
énergétique bon le contexte géopolitique
qui a créé beaucoup de malheur de
souffrance et de difficultés on le sait
a eu quand même pour conséquence de
mobiliser tout le monde sur les efforts
de sobriété énergétique ce sujet qui
d'habitude est très impopulaire s'est
révélé extrêmement efficace et nous nous
avons constaté depuis enfin au cours de
l'année qui s'est écoulée en fait une
baisse entre 7 et 10% sur l'ensemble de
des bâtiments que nous gérons c'est je
trouve extrêmement significatif et nous
pensons que nous nous pouvons poursuivre
et même accentuer les progrès dans ce
domaine c'est un sujet donc qui nous
semble absolument prioritaire
deuxièmement sur les vecteurs
énergétiques bon on a devant nous on le
sait une croissance programmée des
besoins d'électricité et le bâtiment y
prendrait clairement sa part
pour répondre à cette tendance et bien
on a bien sûr un outil précieux avec le
parc nucléaire qui existe mais on sait
que même rafraîchit il va il va vieillir
et donc il est crucial à nos yeux
d'accompagner cette transition avec un
développement massif des renouvelables
sur la production électrique je pense
que l'application de la loi accélération
des énergies renouvelables est assez qui
était garde très important
comme il est tout autant crucial de
veiller à la résilience de notre système
énergétique c'est un point clé j'y
insiste pour en arriver sur mon
troisième point en disant que le contenu
de l'ambition très forte posée par les
textes européens 42% d'énergie
renouvelable en 2030 55 % de gaz est
fait de faire de moins en 2030 bon
ça suppose d'utiliser en complément de
l'électricité d'autres énergies les gaz
verts et des carbonés en particulier le
biométhane et plus tard l'hydrogène mais
aussi et on l'oublie trop souvent la
chaleur et le froid renouvelables qui
sont d'ailleurs très souvent
issus de ressources énergétiques du
territoire avec la biomasse la
géothermie la récupération de chaleur
fatale sur les sites industriels du
territoire et qui j'ajoute permettent
aussi de déployer des solutions
à haute performance énergétique les
réseaux de chaleur notamment c'est pas
seulement un outil pour utiliser du
renouvelable mais c'est un outil qui
combine le renouvelable et l'efficacité
d'un système de production d'énergie
et puis peut-être pour terminer sur ce
propos un peu générique je voudrais
illustrer la nécessité d'une vision
systémique
en prenant l'exemple des choix d'iragaz
je pense que je ne vous surprendrai pas
en évoquant ce thème on entend un peu
ici ou là l'idée d'interdire les choix
dans les bâtiments et dans les logements
bon
je vais même pas évoquer la question
enfin la dimension sociale d'une telle
mesure bien sûr mais simplement si l'on
fait ça ça veut dire qu'il faut ajouter
20 gigawatts de pointe électrique d'ici
2035 c'est-à-dire 13 EPR bon
je n'insiste pas non plus sur la
dépendance massive à l'Asie si on
faisait ça puisque l'Asie et le leader
de la production des pompes à chaleur à
ce stade on voit bien que sur cet
exemple précis ça ne tient pas la route
pour le dire trivialement et nous notre
préconisation elle est d'une autre
nature elle consiste bien sûr à
améliorer la performance énergétique
pour ceux qui sont dotés de ces
chaudières à gaz il y en a à peu près 3
millions qui d'ici 2030 seront vétustes
qu'il faudra changer notre préconisation
c'est pour la moitié
et notamment dans le collectif de les
remplacer par des chaudières à très
haute performances énergétique
d'ailleurs dégage une économie de
l'ordre de 30% par rapport aux
consommations précédentes et pour
l'autre moitié un million et demi de
chaudière par des pompes à chaleur
hybrides pompe chaleur hybride c'est
celle qui permet de combiner l'usage
électrique avec une pompe à chaleur
classique je dirais et l'usage de la
combustion du gaz singulièrement lorsque
la pompe à chaleur ne marche pas au fond
c'est à dire dans les périodes de pointe
importante
et puis puisque dans ce scénario là ça
veut dire qu'on continue à utiliser du
gaz notre préconisation c'est d'allouer
le biogaz dont on pense qu'il faut
d'ailleurs poursuivre le développement
au bâtiment ce qui permettrait donc de
décarboner cette partie des chaudières
qui demeurerait et de prendre en compte
dans le DPE la valeur des des émissions
de gaz du biogaz pour ne pas pénaliser
la valeur patrimoniale des propriétaires
qui auraient fait ce choix de cette
énergie verte
alors maintenant meilleur encore pour
terminer mon propos des éléments très
concrets sur le sur le sujet du jour il
y a bien sûr des moyens financiers très
importants qui sont à louer à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments je
crois que notre représentante de la DGC
hier cité une liste qui si j'en ai fait
la somme rapidement doit être à peu près
autour de 10 milliards d'euros par an
quand même donc c'est tout à fait
considérable et face à ça nous on a deux
constats majeurs le premier constat
c'est un problème d'efficacité parce que
même si tous les acteurs soulignent au
fond certains progrès ils sont temps d'à
peu près tous pour constater que la
nature des aides et leur efficacité
relative ne permet pas en fait de
réduire la consommation finale d'énergie
dans les volumes escomptés il faut donc
changer de rythme c'est très clair pour
tout le monde
puis un deuxième sujet qui nous est
apparu c'est au fond le problème de
fraude décodélinquance là qui vient
perturber au fond le bon fonctionnement
des dispositifs en place et qui
malheureusement trop souvent
pensons-nous un site à une modification
régulière des textes et des dispositifs
et donc dans ce contexte là j'en viens
quelques suggestions la première c'est
il nous paraît absolument indispensable
d'assurer une stabilité et une
prévisibilité à plusieurs années des
dispositifs
vous savez la rénovation et l'énergie
c'est une affaire de temps long on peut
le regretter mais c'est comme ça assez
long temps d'ailleurs pour les décisions
que pour la mise en oeuvre et d'ailleurs
pour le temps de retour au fond donc il
faut du temps de la visibilité de
l'instabilité que nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui pour que l'ensemble des
acteurs évidemment puisse sereinement
décliner les programmes de réalisation
ensuite nous pensions que le traitement
de l'écho délinquance qui est évidemment
nécessaire
doit se faire donc sans modifier de
manière intempestif les dispositifs
alors
comment je dirais
ne pas sacrifier l'essentiel au
traitement de l'écho délinquance
je dirais mettre les moyens à hauteur du
problème traiter les sujets à la source
avec probablement plus de vigueur par la
DGCCRF par la gendarmerie avec des
croisements de fichiers peut-être plus
importants entre les acteurs privés
publics avec des sanctions réelles mais
sans arrêter la dynamique de rénovation
c'est ça que que nous pensons et puis
enfin comme comme beaucoup on ne
souhaite pas opposer la baisse de la
consommation d'énergie et le
verdissement de l'énergie utilisée
infinie mais bien de les combiner de
manière positive et ici aussi on vous
propose quelques suggestions d'abord
pour baisser les consommations
sur les sur la question de la rénovation
par geste ou la rénovation globale on
considère que si bien sûr la rénovation
globale est souhaitable en pratique elle
est très complexe parce que elle
présente des freins psychologiques
logistique financier que ce soit
d'ailleurs dans le collectif comme dans
l'individuelle et donc nous suggérons
d'une part d'inciter le déploiement de
bouquet de solutions plutôt que le geste
unique ou le truc global au fond c'est
une espèce de situation un peu
intermédiaire intelligente
des bouquets plus efficaces que des
gestes isolés et ensuite d'autre part
d'inciter au-delà de ça un parcours de
rénovation dans le temps
avec pour les installations
individuelles
un bonus incitatif à engager un nouveau
geste de rénovation par exemple dans les
deux à trois ans suivant le précédent et
puis dans les installations collectives
un mécanisme en fait
identique mais sur une probablement plus
longue période tout simplement pour
prendre en compte le processus
décisionnel dans les copropriétés en
particulier qui est singulièrement plus
long évidemment et on le regrette
d'ailleurs que dans la les parties
individuelles
ensuite
quelque chose qui nous a frappé c'est
que l'ADEME a évalué que les économies
d'énergie générée réellement par le
dispositif des certificats d'économie
d'énergie
représente moins de la moitié des
économies d'énergie théorique
comptabilisées par le dispositif
quelque part et donc ce que nous
suggérons dans le secteur du tertiaire
et du résidentiel avec chauffage
collectif une incitation très forte pour
ne pas dire plus à déployer les contrats
de performance énergétique vous savez ce
sont des contrats en fait qui
garantissent les économies annoncées
dans la durée
ça ça peut se faire en bonifiant de
manière très forte les actions de
rénovation qui sont couvertes par ces
garanties de contrats de performance
énergétique
contrat de performance énergétique
d'ailleurs qui assure aujourd'hui toutes
les sociétés de service en efficacité
énergétique qui adhèrent la feden en
particulier je crois que vous avez
additionné son président
donc ces sociétés s'engagent sur un
niveau de performance c'est très simple
en fait on était vous consommez 100 on
fait un certain nombre d'actions qui
vous amènent à espérer 60 vous ne
désespérez plus vous les avez puisque
les sociétés en question s'engagent et
si vous consommez 70 n'ont pas 60 et
bien les 10 en plus sont pris en charge
financièrement par la société qui s'y
était engagée
enfin sur les bâtiments collectifs on
constate que le dispositif m'imprime
rénove est au fond très peu développé
très peu déployés ils représentent je
crois 5% des fonds alloués nous nous
suggérons de les renforcer sur cette
cible en particulier sur les
copropriétés
pour
adapter le taux et l'assiette par
logement pour en renforcer sa pertinence
probablement à hauteur pour commencer de
l'ordre de 300 millions d'euros
sur les copropriétés enfin et pour
terminer sur le verdissement de la
chaleur qui se combine à ce que je viens
de dire
il est clair que le dispositif du fonds
de chaleur qui existe à montrer son
extraordinaire efficacité
et à tel point qu'aujourd'hui il est
saturé en vérité
et donc il faut impérativement pour nous
augmenter la dotation à ce fond pour que
les projets puissent se réaliser
aujourd'hui la dotation de 2023 elle est
consommée alors qu'on a un peu plus de
30 je crois le 32 projets exactement de
réseau de chaleur nouveau
qui sont encore dans la file d'attente
c'est des gros projets mais c'est des
projets fondamentaux pour les bâtiments
qui sont accordés parce que en fait
c'est un dispositif pas seulement pour
accéder à de l'énergie renouvelable je
le redis mais aussi pour disposer d'un
système d'efficacité énergétique
partagée l'idée c'est assez simple au
fond c'est plutôt que d'avoir dans
chacun des immeubles une installation
pour par eux-mêmes c'est d'en avoir
peut-être voilà de mettre en commun sur
des centaines d'immeubles des
installations de production et de
transformation d'énergie et ça fait des
nuit tout à fait spectaculaire voilà
c'est un au-delà des heures de ce
renforcement du fond de chaleur vous
savez que il y a un plan que la feden
soutien qui est le plan Marshall qui
consiste en fait à atteindre non pas 40%
on va dire d'énergie renouvelable dans
la chaleur mais 54% à horizon 2030 pour
ça il faut renforcer encore une fois
ce fonds de chaleur en faisant
un développement très très accentué de
la géothermie des pompes à chaleur du
soleil du biogaz de la biomasse et de la
chaleur fatale issue des sites
industriels environnants voilà pour les
messages principaux que je souhaitais
partager avec vous mais sur d'autres
sujets mais je crois qu'on y répondra
avec vos questions
écoutez
[Musique]
effectivement je peux peut-être faire un
point sur le marché des particuliers
donc sur le marché de des particuliers
beaucoup d'éléments qui ont été partagés
par Franck Lacroix sont partagés
notamment la question finalement dans
tout ce qui existe du manque de
stabilité de visibilité avec des
changements très fréquents dans les
dispositifs d'aide
et puis effectivement la complexité donc
ça change beaucoup mais c'est également
très complexe et c'est vrai que pour les
particuliers ce sujet-là est encore plus
difficile puisque effectivement ce ne
sont pas des spécialistes de l'énergie
et donc aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
types d'aides qui existent donc ça c'est
très bien mais pour eux c'est difficile
à comprendre tout ce qui peut exister du
côté des C2E ce qui peut exister du côté
de ma prime rénov
et donc ça je pense que c'est vraiment
un grand point de difficulté
ça peut expliquer la situation actuelle
qu'on observe sur tout ce qui concerne
la rénovation énergétique chez les
particuliers actuellement on ressent
beaucoup d'attentismes
les clients qui prennent contact avec
nous
ne savent plus trop en fait ils nous
disent ben voilà
on nous dit en fait que la chaudière
c'est fini qu'il y aura peut-être des
interdictions donc on hésite finalement
à changer notre raison chaîne chaudière
et en même temps comment s'entendre
qu'il y a beaucoup de contrefaçons sur
la pompe à chaleur et peut-être que les
aides elles vont être arrêtées et donc
on observe à la fois une forte
décroissance de rénovation qui pourrait
être fait sur des chaudières dans du
collectif ou la pompe à chaleur ne passe
pas et puis des particuliers qui
attendent sur la pompe à chaleur avec
des niveaux d'investissement qui peuvent
rester très élevés donc vraiment en gros
problème de stabilité de visibilité et
de complexité sur les aides et
typiquement ce qu'on souhaiterait
proposer sur les aides c'est pourquoi
pas d'essayer de réfléchir avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes sur des
dispositifs peut-être un dispositif de
guichet unique ou finalement le
particulier n'est qu'une seule demande à
faire pour qu'ils sachent finalement
toutes les aides dont il peut bénéficier
et ensuite peut-être réfléchir à des
systèmes alors j'ouvre les guillemets
mais de tiers payants ou le particulier
finalement ne déboursera que la somme
qui lui revient à charge après prise en
compte des différentes aides et
aujourd'hui il y a certaines entreprises
engie le fait au travers de ces filiales
il y a certaines entreprises qui font ça
mais ça reste limité et la plupart des
particuliers sont seuls face à cette à
cette complexité
un élément aussi qui est très important
effectivement et qui franc qu'on a parlé
sur l'aspect éco délinquance c'est vrai
que cette écoule délinquance elle a
beaucoup été générée par des dispositifs
d'aide à 1 euro
et donc ça il y a probablement un gros
retour d'expérience à faire en se disant
que il faut déterminer le juste milieu
des aides quand on est trop agressif sur
les aides masser un boulevard pour un
certain nombre voilà de société
coderlinquante quant à contrario on n'en
met pas assez ça arrête immédiatement
les interventions on a vraiment des Stop
and Go en permanence et finalement ce
qui en pâtissent le plus de voilà de ces
arrêts sur les offres à 1 euro c'est
plus les entreprises qui sont qui sont
sérieuses qui ont essayé de développer
des offres de former effectivement leurs
intervenants leur conseiller leur
techniciens alors que les échos
délinquants vont surfer d'une offre à 1
euro à une autre offre un euro donc
l'idéal ça serait pour tout ce qui
concerne la détermination des nouveaux
dispositifs de pouvoir faire des études
d'impact et de bien se poser la question
de finalement c'est quoi le bon prix
c'est quoi le bon niveau du reste à
charge pour être dans quelque chose qui
est équilibré vertueux
et ça ça serait une vraie amélioration
du dispositif parce qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas
d'études d'impact dans les concertations
qui sont qui sont menées au moment de la
réflexion sur les sur les dispositifs
d'aide et puis le dernier point
peut-être que je peux souligner sur sur
les particuliers ça a été déjà été
souligné par Franck la croix c'est la
problématique effectivement de aussi de
du rythme de la rénovation
on pense probablement qu'il faut un peu
tous les systèmes sur des clients
particuliers quand on est habitant dans
une maison ou dans un appartement un
geste de rénovation isolé peut être
parfois très facile très rapide à faire
et amener beaucoup de réduction de
consommation une je le redis une
chaudière très haute performance
énergétique c'est 30% de consommation de
moins donc des missions de moins de CO2
etc
en revanche faire une rénovation globale
quand on est habitant dans un logement
quand on est une famille ou quand on est
un coupe de personnes âgées ça peut être
très compliqué donc effectivement
ça serait bien de pouvoir raisonner sur
un bouquet de solutions partant de voilà
de l'acte isolé jusqu'à l'agne global en
passant par des bouquets et
effectivement comme ce qui a été dit
précédemment de pouvoir inciter les
particuliers qui ont envie de s'engager
dans une démarche par étape
merci beaucoup donc je vais sans plus
tarder laisser la parole à au rapporteur
merci madame le Président te remercie
pour vos interventions et vos et vos
précisions
moi j'avais plusieurs réflexions et puis
un certain nombre un certain nombre de
questions c'est vrai que vous avez parce
que je trouve déjà intéressant c'est que
en tant que vendeur d'électricité
puisque c'est votre le fait que
justement vous mettiez en alerte sur le
fait du tout électrique en fait et je
trouve ça assez intéressant parce que ça
ça rejoint un certain nombre d'auditions
qu'on est qu'on ait pu faire
sur le fait d'aborder justement cette
question de la
rénovation la rénovation énergétique
c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir un axe
assez assez je dirais simple en se
disant des carbone donc on passe tout en
électrique et puis le tour est joué et
on arrivait le problème quoi donc je
vois que ça c'est pas si simple que ça
et que ça pose quelques problèmes et
puis en plus on règle pas la question du
la question du confort la question de la
réduction du coût de l'énergie et du
coup de l'électricité
qu'on a bien le besoin d'agir sur les
deux tableaux à la fois sur la sobriété
donc la limitation des des perditions et
puis ensuite sur le système de chauffage
et de plutôt avoir une diversification
sur le système de chauffage en fonction
de
je dirais même des localités de la où
existe quoi et je pense que sur les
réseaux de chaleur c'est
particulièrement particulièrement
important
donc là c'était plus une plus une
réflexion après sur sur ce que vous
dites je pense que c'est un autre aspect
aussi qu'on a beaucoup entendu sur on va
dire entre rénovation par gestes et
rénovation globale et on va dire un peu
l'intermédiaire qui est plutôt sur le
parcours et notamment aussi sur des
bouquets de d'intervention
qui peuvent permettre justement à
avoir une visibilité sur les types
d'interventions qu'il faudrait faire et
dans quel sens on fait ces interventions
et peut-être n'en faire qu'une mais en
tout cas de savoir que voilà par
laquelle je commence et d'avoir cette
visibilité sur d'autres types
d'interventions
c'est vrai que je regardais votre
vous parler de guichet unique en tout
cas et d'avoir justement toute cette
accompagnement je regardais votre votre
site internet enfin quand on va et vous
n'êtes pas les seuls mais je trouve que
on a une multiplication en fait de sites
et c'est vrai quelqu'un qui connaît pas
va aller taper soit ma prime rénove soit
voilà c'est ce que j'ai fait du coup
j'ai ma prime rénove et on tombe dessus
du coup c'est vrai que on a quand même à
chaque fois une orientation quand même
sur du geste simple enfin je trouve que
la manière dont les choses sont
présentées c'est quand même oui plutôt
aller vers du changement de chaudière ou
changement de menuiserie mais aller vers
des choses comme ça assez simple et
c'est vrai qu'il manque peut-être tout
cet aspect de renvoyer en tout cas
justement peut-être sur une plateforme
commune d'accompagnement en fait pour
que y ait un accompagnement qui soit
peut-être indépendant en tout cas qui
permet justement de faire ce que vous
parliez de ce passeport en tout cas ce
bouquet qui est ensuite après
l'utilisateur il arrache engie ou chez
quelqu'un d'autre point après voilà
du coup je voulais avoir votre avis par
rapport à ça parce que j'ai l'impression
aussi qu'en terme de lisibilité la
multiplication en fait de ces acteurs
n'aide pas en tout cas à cette à cette
lisibilité
sur aussi le lien entre ma prime rénove
et puis les C2E c'est vrai que la même
manière en terme de lisibilité on a des
moyens très différents de financement
avec des politiques aussi assez
différentes vous avez parlé des des
combles à 1 euro etc qui étaient parfois
d'ailleurs en contradiction avec ce
qu'il pouvait se faire sur ma prime
rénov vous soyez demande et donc on
réfléchit plutôt à savoir comment
on va pas dire c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas fusionner les deux mais en tout cas
d'avoir en tout cas une approche un peu
plus semblable sur l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs et est-ce que du coup c'est
des choses que vous avez réfléchi en
tout cas est-ce que vous avez des
éléments sur cette sur cet aspect là
vous avez également qui a parlé du
contrat de performance énergétique qui
est aussi je trouve intéressant ma seule
question était de savoir comment parce
que c'est vrai qu'avec les outils que ça
soit
Linky Gaspard etc on peut vérifier
contrôler en tout cas les les
utilisations et la consommation
électrique à un moment et après
rénovation il y a quand même toute la
question de l'usage et donc comment on
intègre cette question de l'usage et on
s'est en plus que quand on passe du
Passeur thermique à un bâtiment un peu
mieux
isolé on peut avoir une consommation qui
peut même monter parce que avant les
gens ne se chauffaient pas ou en tout
cas voilà donc il y a surtout cet aspect
là où où utiliser d'autres moyens de
chauffage parce que j'ai vu ça aussi
c'est que la consommation électrique est
facile à contrôler on va dire si les
gens utilisent pas des bains d'huile ou
des choses comme ça pendant une période
arrête ensuite et passe en électrique
ben on va voir une augmentation de la
consommation et donc voilà qui sera pas
forcément réel donc comment en tout cas
sur ces contrats de performance qui sont
assez adaptés sur le tertiaire et plus
facile en fait à mettre en oeuvre on
peut les adapter sur sur le logement
logement individuel
et puis peut-être une dernière question
sur le RGE puisque engie et labellisé
RGE qu'est-ce que vous pensez sur cette
cette labellisation peut-être sur son
évolution et
sur en fait l'intérêt de l'aviation et
derrière ça peut-être aussi une question
sur le contrôle en fait des travaux
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est plutôt
sur un axe en disant qu'on a des
entreprises qui ont un label et donc
par du principe que les travaux sont
bien réalisés puisqu'il y a ce label là
mais avec très peu de contrôle en fait
sur sur site et sur du coup
l'amélioration de ce contrôle et puis
peut-être même la bascule sur elle est
plutôt vers du contrôle sur site quel
que soit je dirais la qualification de
l'entreprise
voilà merci
je vais
peut-être simplement répondre et
Florence je pense qui est très
interpellé sur les questions de des
maisons des logements individuelles ce
qui est bien naturel parce que c'est
quand même d'essentiel en fait
d'ailleurs des questions qui qui sont
posées parce que c'est l'accès le plus
complexe en vérité
simplement sur le point que vous évoquez
sur l'alerte autour du tout électrique
et donc face à ça en fait la réalité
pragmatique qui consiste à dire il y a
pas une solution mais il y a un ensemble
de solutions je pense que la question
des des réseaux de chaleur elle est
quand même très illustrative et vous
avez raison de de le souligner parce
qu'au fond la première des priorités
qu'on peut avoir avant d'aller utiliser
une énergie qui vient de loin certes si
elle était fabriquée avec les techniques
renouvelables c'est de se dire au fond
qu'est-ce que comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour être plus efficace là où nous
sommes en fait dans un à proximité de
nous et c'est le principe même des
réseaux de chaleur qui ne se contente
pas de partager comme je le disais tout
à l'heure d'ailleurs une infrastructure
c'est plutôt par chacun une petite
chaudière on en a une grosse c'est très
différent les réseaux de chaleur c'est
un parcours
d'innovation technologique que personne
n'a en tête en fait quand on a inventé
les réseaux de chaleur dans les années
1900 on va dire début des années 1900
c'était des infrastructures qui se font
qui fonctionnent très haute température
avec de la vapeur d'ailleurs et on
faisait circuler de la vapeur dans les
tuyaux d'eau et on faisait des
échangeurs on va très haut niveau et
donc les rendements étaient mauvais
au fur et à mesure de la première donc
deuxième troisième et quatrième
génération qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on
a trouvé des solutions pour baisser les
niveaux de température de manière
spectaculaire en fait et aujourd'hui ou
plutôt demain je devrais dire on est en
train de réfléchir et en termes de R&D
et d'innovation je crois que c'est très
important avoir des infrastructures qui
vont limiter en fait le recours à la
combustion de manière spectaculaire avec
la géothermique mais avec la géothermie
avec les pompes à chaleur et aussi la
capacité qu'on a en fait à connecter les
immeubles les uns entre les autres pour
faire en sorte que ceux qui ont besoin
de froid au moment où d'autres ont
besoin de chaud échangent tout
simplement leur énergie entre ces
bâtiments et donc ça c'est quelque chose
qui est très intéressant on peut
d'ailleurs parler aussi d'autres
éléments quand on parle de
l'autoconsommation des bâtiments au-delà
donc du chauffage et de l'eau chaude
sanitaire sur la partie électrique on
peut parfaitement et on le fait
d'ailleurs maintenant installer des
équipements de solaire photovoltaïques
sur un bâtiment peut-être plus gros que
d'autres qui se trouve autour et puis
offert en sorte que cette consommation
enfin cette énergie qu'on se produit sur
un bâtiment puisse naturellement
profiter à celui-ci mais aussi à ceux
qui sont à côté et c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler l'autoconsommation
collective qui vient aussi apporter des
éléments très intéressants donc au fond
ce que je veux simplement dire c'est
plutôt que de se demander d'abord quel
type d'énergie centrale produite avec de
du transport de la distribution etc on
pourrait voir c'est comment déjà
ensemble on peut être plus intelligent à
l'échelle d'un territoire et je trouve
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses
intéressantes à faire et d'ailleurs
sur la question que vous m'avez pas
posée mais
sur la question du refroidissement en
matière de à cause de réchauffement de
la planète 4 degrés bon voilà on voit
bien que la vie en période d'été va
devenir compliqué et bien ces
infrastructures collectives permettent
aussi de dégager des solutions très
intéressantes pour la production du
froid pour une raison toute simple c'est
que si vous avez des équipements
individuels de froid ou les utiliser
avec des taux puisque vous disiez une
seule machine à produire du froid en
fait donc elle est jamais à 100% de sa
capacité et dans ce genre de machine si
vous l'utilisez à 20% vous avez un
coefficient de performance qui est très
mauvais mais si vous mettez ça en commun
avec tout le monde alors là vous avez
des modules en fait d'installation qui
chaque module fonctionne à 100%. et donc
là vous êtes beaucoup plus efficace et
en addition de ça vous pouvez puisque
vous êtes en collectif faire ce qu'on
appelle du chauffe du du stockage du
stockage de froid et ça marche de
manière fulgurante donc
préparer le monde de demain à avoir des
infrastructures énergétiques collectives
et quelque chose d'extrêmement précieux
et qui répond je crois aux questions de
une seule solution notamment électrique
[Musique]
sur les questions qu'il y avait plus
très effectivement
aux clients particuliers peut-être ce
que je peux répondre c'est il faut
arriver vraiment à faire quelque chose
qui puisse être complémentaire entre ce
que
les pouvoirs publics peuvent apporter
est-ce que les entreprises du secteur
peuvent apporter
et je pense que effectivement du côté
des pouvoirs publics qui a besoin de
simplifier certainement la façon dont
les informations sont mises à
disposition des particuliers pour
vraiment qui est un endroit où on puisse
se renseigner de façon sûre sur sur les
dispositifs d'aide et qui soit
labellisés par l'État donc ça ça me
paraît important et ça certainement pas
très difficile à concevoir à la période
actuelle et puis il y a un deuxième
sujet qui est finalement
l'accompagnement des clients
particuliers dans ce moment là et là il
y a encore des choses qui peuvent être
jouées par les organismes publics
typiquement et bien par Lana les
accompagnateurs rénaux etc ayant en
parallèle ce qui peuvent être apportés
par les entreprises et c'est vrai que
les entreprises de l'énergie on est
considéré par nos clients comme je
dirais légitime dans ce sujet en fait de
la rénovation énergétique c'est le
principal sujet sur lequel nous
considère légitime au-delà de la
fourniture d'énergie on a tous beaucoup
de clients nous par exemple pour vous
dire on a sur le site internet d'engie
environ 5 millions de Français qui
chaque année viennent sur notre site le
regard etc et donc c'est très
intéressant finalement d'allier les
forces entre l'information qui peut être
donnée l'accompagnement qui peut être
donné par des établissements publics par
l'État etc est-ce que peuvent apporter
les acteurs du secteur
et nous effectivement on peut apporter
aussi de l'accompagnement on a des
conseillé qui sont spécialisés en
efficacité en efficacité énergétique et
à ce stade on n'est pas par exemple
considéré comme pouvant être
candidat à accompagnateurs rénov et on
trouve que c'est dommage parce
qu'effectivement on a même parfois
certains conseillers d'accompagnateurs
rénov qui appellent nos propres
conseillers pour pouvoir effectivement
bien échanger checker donc je pense que
c'est important de travailler sur des
parce qu'en fait les obliger ont été par
principe effectivement et c'est pour ça
je disais que je pense que c'est
intéressant de travailler dans la
complémentarité
pour reprendre votre proposition sur le
guichet unique je pense que c'est bien
que l'État est ces établissements
publics puissent s'organiser pour que
l'information soit beaucoup plus simple
pour pour les clients particuliers puis
de l'autre côté effectivement il faut
aussi qu'on puisse travailler ensemble
parce qu'on a beaucoup de clients parce
qu'ils nous font confiance parce qu'en
plus on a tout intérêt à ce qu'il soit
bien servi pour qu'il reste chez nous
derrière et qu'il soit fidèle on n'a pas
du tout intérêt à faire de la fraude sur
nos clients
donc on pense que ça serait bien d'aller
dans ce sens là et aujourd'hui on est
plutôt à la considéré comme il faut les
mettre à côté et faut pas forcément
travailler avec
eux et après le dernier élément qui me
paraît important au-delà de cet aspect à
mon qui est vraiment l'aspect comment on
donne de l'information comment on
accompagne comment on conseille il y a
l'aspect ensuite quand on passe à
l'action et c'est là où parfois il peut
y avoir des difficultés pour les
particuliers parce qu'il va falloir
qu'ils avancent certaines sommes et ils
vont avoir les aides après et donc c'est
là où on pourrait peut-être réfléchir à
un dispositif qui ressemblerait un peu à
du tiers payant oui effectivement une
fois que le dossier du client
particulier il est validé les bons etc
effectivement qu'il puisse y avoir un
système où lui il n'a déboursé vis-à-vis
de vis-à-vis de de l'artisan qui
l'accompagne que le montant qu'il doit
effectivement payer et après des
systèmes effectivement de flux croisés
entre l'État et les acteurs privés voilà
ça c'est un peu la vision je pense ça
serait vraiment intéressant qu'on y
travaille dans le cadre d'une
concertation
avec avec la DGC avec Lana avec tous les
acteurs
après il y avait un autre sujet qui
était le sujet RGE mais posé la question
alors sur le sujet RGE qu'on pense nous
c'est que c'est une première base il a
le mérite d'exister ce label et ce qui
serait idéal ça serait de le renforcer
le renforcer à Lamont pour mieux
sélectionner les entreprises à qui on
donne ce label ce qui serait aussi quand
même un moyen à la source de limiter les
échos délinquants donc d'être beaucoup
plus exigeant sur la façon de donner ce
label ensuite quand on a ce label
probablement de pouvoir
disposer de formation continue les
techniques évoluent etc donc le sujet de
la formation initiale de la formation
continue et de faire en sorte en fait
qu'il y ait des audits très sérieux qui
permettent derrière de retirer ce label
lorsqu'il y a un manquement par rapport
à aux normes qui sont demandées par le
label et aujourd'hui ce qu'on
ce qu'on sait c'est que lorsque les
organismes donc qui attribuent le label
RGE et c'est de l'enlever à certaines
entreprises qui n'ont pas été
suffisamment scrupuleuses ces
entreprises peuvent se retourner vers
les tribunaux et dans plus de 90% des
cas récupère leur labels donc il y a un
vrai sujet finalement là-dessus de
monter en compétences et de sérieux de
ce que ça veut dire avoir ce label
comment on peut le retirer et c'est pas
impossible parce que on a un exemple
dans le secteur de l'énergie alors qui a
été développé il y a des années c'était
pour des raisons de sécurité pas des
raisons de de décoderlinquance mais on
peut faire le parallèle c'était
justement pour les professionnels du gaz
naturel et ils ont ce qu'on appelle des
certificats de conformité qui sont
délivrés par un organisme qui s'appelle
habitat plus c'est extrêmement sérieux
et donc quand on perd ce label parce
qu'on a eu un audit on est obligé à
toutes toutes les visites d'être
accompagnées par un auditeur et donc du
coup les professionnels sont hyper
motivés à jamais perdre ce label parce
que sinon en fait je viens très très
compliqué donc il y a certainement un
moyen de renforcer
le label RGE et que pour autant vous
pensez pas que en le renforçant on
n'arriverait pas à aux résultats inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on manque
d'entreprise qui sont labellisées RGE
qui beaucoup d'entre elles préfèrent
renoncer à être labellisé pour
différentes raisons parce que c'est
compliqué et donc j'entends ce que vous
dites qui va plutôt le bon sens mais ce
que ça serait pas de nature finalement à
diminuer encore peut-être le nombre
d'entreprises labellisée RGE alors qu'on
en a besoin que le ministre de
l'Économie annonce pour 2025
une augmentation assez faramineuse du
nombre d'entreprises RG je ne sais pas
si ça se produira donc voilà c'est un
petit peu le difficulté de trouver un
équilibre certainement si quelque chose
qui doit s'étudier se concerter
certainement que la formation initiale
est très importante peut-être que les
entreprises doivent être aidés dans
cette formation initiale
et effectivement une fois qu'on a le
label il faut le mériter donc oui il y a
certainement une difficulté là-dessus
mais ça doit pouvoir se traiter par un
accompagnement et peut-être des aides du
coup pour permettre aux entreprises
d'arriver en qualité et de toute façon
ce qu'on se dit même si c'est même si on
n'est pas dans le domaine de la fraude
on a quand même tout intérêt à avoir des
artisans qui soient bien formés puis ça
peut créer aussi beaucoup d'emplois
finalement donc il faut arriver
peut-être à vraiment le construire comme
une filière en fait une filière
d'excellence
et peut-être juste pour finir sur ce
sujet des contrôles là où ça serait très
vertueux de fonctionner comme ça sur RGE
c'est que ça permettrait derrière de
diminuer les contrôles a posteriori qui
sont fait sur les chantiers C2E qui sont
de plus en plus nombreux qui présentent
un certain coût et qui sont aujourd'hui
le palliatif qu'on a tous trouvé
ensemble pour effectivement compenser
peut-être la façon dont Rieux et trop
facilement donner
le
rapporteurs de performance énergétique
là du coup sur ce comment on intègre en
fait le
la consommation en tout cas l'usage des
particuliers
alors sur les particuliers on commence à
réfléchir à des systèmes incitatifs donc
on n'est pas encore à des contrats de
performance énergétique mais ça a été
finalement une des grandes conséquences
de la période compliquée qu'on a tous
vécu en 2022 dans le domaine de
l'énergie il y a eu tout un discours
très important à la fois des pouvoirs
publics et des grands groupes de
l'énergie pour inciter à la sobriété et
on a tous été amenés à se dire comment
on va utiliser le fait que nous ayons
maintenant des compteurs communicants
notamment en électricité qui sont très
précis de façon à permettre finalement à
nos clients d'avoir beaucoup plus
conscience des quantités d'énergie qu'il
consomme et derrière de leur donner la
possibilité finalement en ayant plus
conscience de les de réduire leur
consommation donc on a réfléchi à des
systèmes et ce qui marche très bien
après un an de crise on l'a vu c'est des
systèmes où on met à disposition des
clients donc du digital dans des
applications
et où on leur dit voilà si vous arrivez
sur cette journée là qui va être une
journée particulièrement tendue par
exemple pour le réseau électrique à
consommer tant de pour cent de moins
vous aurez un bonus en fait on est
plusieurs fournisseurs à voir l'avoir
fait comme c'était en test chez nous on
n'avait pas fait énormément de
communication on a 400000 clients qui se
sont inscrits rien qu'en ayant la
notification sur sur l'espace client et
ce qui les intéressait c'était l'aspect
évidemment incitation j'ai intérêt à le
faire et puis l'aspect je suis guidé
donc deux jours avant ils avaient
effectivement dans leur application un
message en disant voilà votre objectif
vous pouvez le faire en décalant votre
machine à laver ne pas mettre votre
sèche-linge ou en donner un certain
nombre d'exemples et en fait ça a très
très bien fonctionné et les clients qui
ont participé à ça en consommer en
moyenne 8% de moins que les clients qui
ne participaient pas donc ce que ça nous
a montré c'est une première piste c'est
qu'il faut qu'au niveau des fournisseurs
en tout cas on travaille sur des
systèmes incitatifs ça passera comme ça
probablement dans un premier temps sur
les clients partis sur les clients
particuliers en fait c'est la meilleure
façon de les intéresser et l'aspect
facilité aussi
j'en profite pour compléter parce que
c'est vrai que c'est le point commun qui
vient d'être évoquer avec les contrats
de performance énergétique du monde plus
collectif le monde collectif l'intérêt
d'un contrat de performance énergétique
c'est je le disais tout à l'heure vous
étiez à 100 on fait des travaux des
changements etc d'hiver et hop on passe
à 60 c'est bien de passer à 60 mais il
faut y rester et c'est le risque
classique qu'on a dans ces trucs là et
donc le contrat de performance
énergétique permet de mesurer cette
partie mais aussi de mettre en place
dans la durée un dispositif de dialogue
d'information vis-à-vis des occupants
qui nous aident justement à rester
efficace dans la durée parce que le
deuxième risque objectivement de
beaucoup de rénovation c'est en fait que
voilà ça ne dure malheureusement qu'un
temps et je ferais pas qu'on creuse non
plus trop fort parce que on sait qu'à
l'avance on va remonter
alors je crois qu'il y avait Philippe
Folliot qui voulait poser une question
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
remporteur madame messieurs
l'Union européenne dans le cadre de ce
qu'on appelle la taxonomie si ma mémoire
ne me fait pas défaut a considérer que
le nucléaire donc l'électricité mais
aussi le gaz était considéré comme des
énergies
écologiques de transition pour prendre
la terminologie par rapport à cela
parallèlement il a été décidé que
il y aurait un programme de remplacement
de toutes les chaudières à gaz par des
chaudières système électrique et en
toute état de cause essayer de sortir le
gaz
en la matière et donc ma question est ma
question est simple c'est que
[Musique]
parfaitement raison parce que quelque
part derrière la question j'entendais un
peu la réponse
pour dire que il y a pas une seule
énergie qui fera le système énergétique
de demain c'est une absurdité concrète
pour des raisons très simples et
techniques et vous parlez des chaudières
gaz si on devait supprimer toutes les
chaudières gaz qui arrivent à
l'expiration d'ici 2030 il faudrait que
on augmente la capacité de production
d'électricité en pointe de 20 GW c'est
très EPR on ne pense pas qu'on soit en
état de le faire donc c'est juste à
l'échelle du système pas possible mais à
l'échelle des maisons et des habitats
collectifs ça n'est pas non plus
possible pour une raison toute simple
c'est que les pompes à chaleur elle
fonctionne bien jusqu'à une certaine
niveau de température il faut si vous
tombez en dessous elle fonctionne plus
très mal et donc il faut quelque chose
qui permet d'amener un niveau de
température supérieure ça s'appelle
par exemple des chaudières à gaz et
c'est pas un problème c'est pas un
problème dès lors que leur utilisation
diminue de manière très importante mais
ça vient en complément je suis
absolument convaincu qu'à l'échelle du
système national tout comme c'est le cas
à l'échelle d'une ville d'un réseau de
chaleur voire même d'un bâtiment c'est
une mixité de vecteurs énergétiques qui
est la solution optimum et c'est bien
comme ça qu'il faut le faire et
d'ailleurs on fait beaucoup nous
d'efforts dans les réseaux je reviens
sur nos réseaux de chaleur ou de froid
pour diversité diversifier pardon le mix
énergétique et nos techniciens qui avant
faisait fonctionner je dirais une
chaudière à fioul par exemple
aujourd'hui ils ont une époque qu'ils
aient dans leur installation 4 5 ou 6
sources énergétiques différentes que
l'on met dans une logique de de
priorisation de mériteur on appelle ça
en disant d'abord faire chauffer
la biomasse parce que c'est le plus
efficace et puis il faut pas que ça
bouge donc la biomasse c'est le socle et
puis après on va récupérer l'énergie sur
la station d'épuration des eaux parce
que voilà c'est quasiment gratuit et on
met c'est pas tout le temps parce que il
y a des flux et puis on va combler le
trou ou gérer la pointe avec du gaz à la
fin le gaz et 10 15 20% beaucoup moins
qu'avant mais ça s'inscrit dans un
système énergétique qui se veut
décarboner au maximum
malgré tout qui est efficace parce que
le client il attend aussi l'énergie
quand il en a besoin
y a-t-il d'autres questions la part de
nos collègues ce rapporteur non
et bien écoutez Madame Monsieur Merci
beaucoup de votre de vos interventions
et on vous souhaite une bonne après-midi
merci